bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ci siamo tornati sugo
simulator tra l'altro cos'è praticamente
ragazzi uscita la patch di god simulator
e non opec cos'è toschi voleva giocare
la prima ma non ero a casa in questi
giorni ragazzi appena sono rientrato
l'ho fatta subito e tra l'altro ci sarà
ovviamente devo scegliere classici sono
tutte le classi tanto sono bellissime
tra l'altro c'è il mago il meeting il
microonde giustamente il micro ci
mancherebbe io direi di fare ma che
belli sono il calciatore bellissimo
facciamo mamma agisce anche il più figo
è una cosa si può già partito così è
perché sono su una massa di morti ci
sono dei players di player online che
sanno giocare
buongiorno a della leggenda vieni qua è
morto
ok ma già oggi fanno mai fossero che
posso leccare gli altri che figlio cosa
succede alla gara ok ok l'asian perde
vediamo di riuscire sei un [ __ ] genio
sei salito è salito anche in groppa in
questo vedere la gente online ragazzi è
qualcosa di fantastico munque hanno
rifatto
sì sì che investi non è non è che
possiamo
io vengo la gente ama l'azione magia
cioè se io premo r faccio
io posso tipo buttare a terra la gente
scusa io vi giuro che non ce l'ho con te
eva ma siete [ __ ] nel cervello non è
questo video si sono effettivamente
players sono computer che si fingono
player però va bene uno a ok più avrà
certo è una cosa nuova per questa
ragazza è la magia più [ __ ] che io abbia
mai visto nella mia vita amico mio ti
piace se magia niente mori ragazzi la
gente muore in sto gioco non si sa
perché devo capire ascoltami è proprio
un cazzo le veliste carte è lei che
funziona le carte fanno rivivere la
gente fantastica posso salvare sto tizio
nell'inventario praticamente ma perché
andiamo avanti perché sono finimmo più
praticamente è un gioco tipo a quest
benvenuto a braves on the beach e poi è
morta quindi babel in grecia verso la
devo portarle la la la la soda questa
qui ok la premiata no cazzo ok lo prendo
preso preso presa la questo è più
difficile della storia mai fatta una
cosa così non lo so ma credo che tipo il
mio personaggio salti più in alto degli
altri perché sono finito fuori dalla
mappa è bellissimo solo che non solo me
cazzo dovrebbe torneo giovanile che
possiamo andare goccia air perfetta di
mago shire che la gente scompare quando
passa quel punto non lo so perché lei
non ce ne frega niente ragazzi andiamo
anche questa lost uil ma russo scolta
zia sei veramente brutta quindi ti
meriti una punizione lo mancata un pò
nicchia che mira di merda ciò ecco la
dieta o lo fa adesso l'ho presa ragazzo
ha fatto fare un buongiorno ascolta zia
mimi siti dove dove stai andando la
prendo la prendo la prendo la prendo
eccoti fatto preso le sisters mele
perché ci sono meno ovunque bring five
apple su steve morse scott zio che cazzo
ti balli
[Musica]
khatami steve steve works ti porto delle
mele o che allora questa è una questa ma
se c'è intorno
massei demente pure tu qual è il senso
di questa queste le mele cela intorno se
non ce la fai a prenderle ricami il
senso di sta roba sia prova bene ecco è
salvato la mia vita certo sto sbloccando
delle cose che non so nemmeno io intanto
ci sono un casino di questo e sembrati
forno allora io che ho giocato di
pochettino a world of warcraft più o
meno è uguale praticamente perché ho
trovato un nemico però vedere se riesco
a batterlo e non sono sicuro però se mi
sa che botto ragazzi ho appena scoperto
la mia mossa finale sparatevi questa
guardate che roba che lo manca e va bene
è da perfezionare va bene si è salvato
per miracolo lo sai
ecco come non detto hanno costruito
delle macchine che ho già capito devo
distruggere quegli stronzi di prima devo
dire ecco lo staff ci avrei scommesso da
fermi un attimo poi l'ho preso
che mira di merda cioè eccolo ecco ahia
ahia
ma se lo leggo in funzione uguale lo
leggo così sì ma non c'è ma perché io
leccando alba ma ovviamente si leccando
delle macchine che sono quattro volte me
io le butto giù mi sembra giusto ecco
quattro su cinque ragazzi manca l'ultimo
check in è stato un fenomenale ragazza
una donna coi trick shot delle delle
papere giusta ma che belle sono
ragazzate mia zia
ecco perfetto le belle velata somma
sorprenderemo su prendere magie nuove
con i livelli che passò tipo una fionda
ma io posso lanciare così non ci crederò
mai ma veramente ragazzi e ragazze è
certo qualcuno mi spiega cosa sta
succedendo ma non lo voglio neanche
sapere benissimo posso lasciarmi andare
ti fossi lì perfetto dove sono finito
sua vita a tullia tristram voglio rosita
adesso se io entropa detto voglio lo si
tav assolutamente se è una persona cosa
ci fai in cima al tetto di un mulino
amico mio fagli vedere di che cosa sei
capace scorta mio zio la vedi questa non
è neanche tutto aspetta qua non mancato
da non fa a palle di fuoco proprio che
prefetto adesso lo prete promesso che
cosa fai qua ecco perché adesso che cosa
hai da dire zio anche morta questa mia
uscita benissimo cosa dovresti mai
essere tu miranda la sirena si c'è
ovviamente mi sembra una sirena a tutti
gli effetti scotta mia età l'altro
ciancia della vita questa non muore
subito va bene che le sirene sono metà
pesce metà donna per lo scasso
ascoltami non posso stare non posso
sentire questo sono troppo a lungo
tu uccidi il più possibile prendi loro i
loro occhi per che cosa ti servono i
loro occhi va bene ci provo devo
ammazzare delle sirene e prendere degli
assi ma queste non sono banco per il
cazzo sirente
strage strage allucinante uno su cinque
vicano trovare neppure 5 di sti cosi ma
mi spiegate il senso di queste corda
meglio non lasciar perdere
tanto c'è uno morto qua sono miei
bastardo non ti azzardare ecco infatti
secondo me i ragazzi dello stregone è
troppo forte
ho scelto la classe più importante che
potevo prendere l'ho presa ecco ecco la
con la devi toglierti ok debito no
[ __ ] siamo 5 suu kyi ce l'ho fatta
ma gli spunta pure il punto
interrogativo è come warcraft ragazzi è
uguale bellissimo perché stai tenendo
quegli occhi mi hai detto tu di prendere
che cazzo vuoi
ecco infatti un giro che me ma ho capito
lo sono i murlo che per fare vabbè ballo
a capirne è proprio una sirena un muro
vabbè non importa se grazie ai ragazzi
credetemi che della mia vita
credevo di poter fare qualsiasi cosa ma
invece mi sono ridotto a scontrarmi
contro dei pesci mutanti in un
videogioco di un pesce mutante che mi dà
una una quest perfetto
certo in questo caso però solo di
martedì è perché perché sono non posso
mi spiega che cosa devo fare
blog non ti spiega un cazzo ma questo
che devo fare questa 0 su 10
devo ammazza ecco vedete dei cosi tipo
questi non a caso c'è qualcosa che ho
capito da resi davanti e che non bisogna
mai accettare questo da un urlo che
cos'è questa roba
io non capisco che cosa fa perché c'è un
cucchiaio grosso così non bilbo ci
mancava bilbo e chiamò anche gandalf da
qualche parte messi snowpark scorta mi
devo scortare sto tizio la taverna
bellissima si ma ti muovi come mia nonna
dio ci stai mettendo una v.no raga io
non potrò mai fire i [ __ ] vieni tu
perché posso mai vederlo camminare come
una lumaca in calore non è possibile
ecco qua è stata eccoci baci si sa che
l'ho fatta regaliamogli del buon vino a
quest'uomo per questa me ecco perfetto
vedi che non sta per niente sverso le
vedi come s'è ripreso subito avranno si
cammina sulle tazze maleducazione perché
ho trovato un c'è un buco che possa
posso entrare qua dentro un dungeon la
prossima area si passiamo il caldo e per
cui io voglio capire dove vi porta dove
siamo una fattoria di mou che non troppo
segre cosa stanno facendo
oddio mi stanno sparando delle mucche
qualcuno mimì mi vuole spiegare che cosa
cazzo a nel cervello il creatore di
questo giorno vorrei capirlo un attimo
scusate perché ci sono delle mucche che
stanno in piedi e che si tengono il
pacco e che sparano l'agi riser dagli
occhi e che svengono sino ad alemanno
non dagli occhi dalle mammelle gius
ovviamente la poesia di questo gioco
ragazzi non la capirò mai per adesso
direi che fosse conclude qui perché
alquanto strano si è fatto tutto gioco
però va beh quindi ragazzi servito mi è
piaciuto come asset ha lasciato
argomento mi piace anche a parte di
facebook che come ogni video straten
descrizione [ __ ] prestito prestiti
iscrivetevi ci vediamo al prossimo vi do
è perché il mago fa questo effetto ok
per direi che funziona non vi allarmate
regali o io faccio riparazioni
funzionali in 4 secondi belle ragazze